[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen micro
fällt meine lieben freunde wir dürfen
gar nicht lange zeit verlieren denn
heute steht wieder extrem viel auf der
to-do-liste wir haben hier vorne noch
immer den kopf des schafes stehen was er
vor einigen folgen leider von uns
gegangen ist und heute möchte ich hier
neben einen kopf setzen
da er auch die kuh leider letzte folge
von uns gegangen ist und wir
dementsprechend heute auch wieder keine
ultra fröhliche folge haben denn ich
möchte nach auf jeden fall noch ein
gedicht vortragen
dort hinten in unserer kapelle lkw
kirche auf der trauminsel ich werde
balu mitnehmen weil du lebst noch du
kriegst auch keinen kopf wenn du noch
lebst
nein willst du nicht ich werde auf jeden
fall humor übernehmen und ich werde das
schweinchen auch mit darüber nämlich
weiß gerade nicht wo es ist allerdings
werden die alle mitkommen hinten zu der
insel jedoch um diesen kopf erstmal zu
bauen benötigen wir eine menge also
wirklich eine menge wolle ich wollte das
erst aus keramik oder beton bauen
allerdings habe ich dann meiner test
welt doch mal aus wolle vorgebaut und
deshalb deutlich besser aus von daher
euch erstmal ganz kurze time netz wie
ich rüber fahrer aus festland und einige
schafe suche
[Musik]
ich habe zwar eine menge wolle geholt
und habe auch schon die meisten sachen
vorbereiten die ich benötige allerdings
habe ich keine kakaobohnen die ich für
braunen farbstoff braucht und ich weiß
auch nicht wo ich die braune wolle
hierher habe wahrscheinlich habe ich die
von irgendeinem scharf mal geschert oder
irgendwie so allerdings brauche ich halt
30 braune wolle und das schaff ich nicht
von daher konzentrieren wir uns erstmal
auf eine andere sache und zwar bloß
nicht dafür den bruchstein hier kurz
einen stein werden lassen denn ich
möchte mir einen stein knopf machen
wofür genau ich den benötige werdet ihr
gleich sehen sobald wir rüber fahren zu
unserer trauer in sicht die gedichte
vortragen
diesen stein nehmen wir nun packen jetzt
hier ein und erhalten den stein knopf
und als ich mir jetzt auch noch mal
holen werde ist meinel eine die habe ich
nicht wohin hier und mir eingepackt
damit können wir nämlich einerseits balu
mitnehmen der läuft allerdings hinter
uns her und wir können auch das
schweinchen mitnehmen und hoffentlich
bitte nicht wieder würde hier vorne und
kann jetzt mal erpressen
die hatte ich hier immer noch seitdem
noch scharfe gestorben ist hier vorne
haben wir das schweinchen von daher
kennen wir das mal ganz kurz anderen bei
juni mich auch kurz mit alleine mit und
jetzt glaube ich dass ich mit ihnen
zusammen rüber laufen kann es meiner
trauer insel
mit traurig das sind die beiden letzten
richtigen tiere auf meiner insel weil
das schaf und die kwo einfach gestorben
sind wir sind nun allerdings jetzt auch
hier vorne angekommen und ich werde auch
mal ganz kurz ein eisen schaufel nehmen
und den weg hier fertig machen denn das
gras ist hier gewachsen also einmal hier
hoch und hier an der seite darüber dann
haben jetzt hier auch ein von dem
kriegen weg die beiden werde ich jetzt
hier mit reinnehmen ich hoffe dass das
passt hier mit der tür
allerdings sollte das denke ich kein
problem sein das geht einfach kurz ihren
lauf ihr müsst nacheinander
ja er ist der eine dann der andere
denn so da gibt sich der steht jetzt
auch gleich in natürlich nehme lieber
die laien hier ganz gut man eben wieder
weg so und jetzt bei balu erstmal noch
nicht dann kann ich bin nämlich erstmal
schon mal hier rein mitnehmen so perfekt
so dann setzt jetzt von buddy lineup ich
mal hier kurz machen aber ebenso und
dann nehme ich jetzt kurz das
schweinchen
das ist der abschiedsgottesdienst das
müsst ihr in der passt hier nicht durch
jetzt kannst du sehen wir die tür
abbauen so jetzt klappt auf jeden fall
nämlich in die landauer ab und stelle
nun die fichtenholz tür wieder prozent
war nur einmal kurz bitte hier sitzen
bleiben und weiterhin sitz machen denn
ich meine damen und herren möchte nur
eine rede halten und daher platziere ich
hier mal ganz kurz den knopf und drücke
ihnen
bei der damen und herren
stellt euch einfach vor ihr seid damen
und herren schauen du warst ein gutes
team
doch manchmal war es wo auch wenn
kleiner stier hast mich auf zutiefst
beleidigt
doch uns alle stets verteidigt
egal ob beim überfall oder auf reisen
was du immer mittendrin in unseren
kreisen eine rolle war so flauschig und
sanft
bis ich dich nun habe in den boden
gestampft ein tot
oh je er tut mir so leid ich ging wohl
einen schritt zu weit
wir verbringen die restliche zeit nun
nicht mehr zu zweit und des anderen leid
ist nun ein zweig schauen du warst stets
für alle da und nun stehen wir hier
zusammen am altar
lieber gott
bitte behüte unser verstorbene scharf
es ist so unfassbar lieb und brav
ruhe in frieden
schauen wir haben jetzt zwar keinen
namen für dich dennoch was bei äußerst
beweglich
ein mou von dir war nie eins zu viel
mord ist immer eis am stiel
viele folgen was du mit dabei
auf unserer kleinen reiserei
doch nun hast du ins gras gebissen ich
finde du solltest dich noch nicht
verpassen
was unser schatz unser sonnenschein
jedoch stehen wir hier
allein
wir hoffen dass du nun im himmel bis er
tot ist wirklich ein blöder egoist
du bleibst für immer in unseren herzen
vergehen werden sie nie großen schmerzen
ruhe in frieden
q
jetzt meine damen und herren
wurden auch von unseren gästen
und den trauernden mit menschen tieren
unten und schweinen
einige abschiedsworte
für shawn vorbereitet
[Musik]
und es wurden auch noch vom schwein
abschiedsworte für die meine damen und
herren
das war der gottesdienst
das schaf und die kuh
ich verabschiede mich
im nu
jetzt noch nicht beenden wir sind nicht
mal bei zehn minuten wahrscheinlich ich
werde jetzt mal eben fit ich werde jetzt
mal eben fix in einem bettchen hier
laufen was ich ja hier noch stehen habe
und mich mal ganz kurz eben schlafen
legen sodass die nacht überspringen
können ich habe für heute noch so ein
paar kleider to do's die ich
reinschieben kann die wir auf jeden fall
noch machen müssen ich muss auch erst
mal ganz kurz das essen bevor ich hier
halb von den knochen falle die sache ist
allerdings dass ich auf jeden fall
erstmal das schweinchen und auch meinen
hund balu zurück bringen möchte auf
meine insel denn ich erst mal hier
wenn ihr hier zeigt jetzt mal ganz kurz
aufstehen und jetzt sicher auch
mitnehmen
ich möchte meinen wieder mitnehmen auf
meiner insel denn ich habe keine lust
ist die hier irgendwie in der kirche
verrotten
von daher wird sich hier mal ganz kurz
hier wartet draußen mal ganz kurz die
tür wieder rein und wir machen wir
natürlich verständlich zu schwimmen nun
rüber zu unserer insel eine rüstung hab
ich auch schon ausgezogen ich dachte
schon konzept verloren
ja ich hab so packt hättest du tust auch
vorbereitet die wir auf jeden fall heute
noch machen können ich möchte die ganze
folge beziehen also wollte die ganze
folge eigentlich der beerdigung vom
schaf und der kuh widmen
allerdings möchte ich jetzt auch nicht
mit so einer traurigen folge hier euch
in den feierabend entlassen
von daher müsste auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen was machen wir haben ein ganz
ganz kleine kleinigkeit die mich
allerdings ein bisschen gestört und zwar
geht es dabei um den wasserfall und ich
würde sagen dass wir auch dort einfach
mal direkt raus schwimmen das macht ein
bisschen mehr sind dann kann ich das
nämlich direkt zeigen wie hinten kommt
er dann den kopf hin
daneben das habe ich meiner test wird
schon vorgebaut dass er sehr sehr sehr
sehr geil aus allerdings fehlten dafür
da jetzt wirklich der braune farbstoff
hat den ich leider nur aus kakaobohnen
bekomme und kakaobohnen kriegt man nur
im dschungel
also ich weiß nicht wo bei mir hin
journalist ich habe noch keinen job
gefunden ich lasse die beiden jetzt auch
mal eben kurz von der leine wieder beide
katzen bisschen rumlaufen das tier kommt
da schon hoch also schreibt mir gut und
in die kommentare wo ich kakaobohnen
sonst vielleicht her bekommen könnte
hier wollte ich das ganze allerdings so
bauen sodass der wasserfall wirklich
runter geht ins wasser rein und was mich
auch noch gestört hat war hier vorne
dass das hier nicht so ist ich möchte
mich so bei uns sagt ihr dann im sand
ist ein bisschen schöner abgerundete aus
und
was wir auch noch machen könnten wäre
das wird den quartz hier nehmen wir
haben mich noch 24 grad blöcke das sind
allerdings wo haben wir noch die anderen
wir haben auf jeden fall noch platz
blöcke ich weiß nicht wie die schon
rübergebracht habe allerdings den
wahrscheinlich der fall sein
von daher nehme ich diese quarzgänge
jetzt auch noch mal mit und auch ein
bisschen kohle dann kann ich das nämlich
da hinten schon mal beraten hinten bei
unserer strandhaus werden dort haben wir
immer noch was habe ich verlange ich
schon gemacht
leuchtturm kann ich ab machen friedhof
kann ich auch ab macht das bonner verlag
an ich hab mal steht nur noch
strandvilla dran
schreibt mir immer neue sachen die
kommentare was ich machen soll zunächst
einmal ziehe ich mir jetzt meine rüstung
hier auch wieder an und nehmen das
schild in die hand das hatte ich ja ganz
ganz ganz ganz lange zeit so ein
bisschen vernachlässigt mit dem schild
ganz einfach aufgrund der tatsache
wollen wir denn hier klassik verkauf von
der tatsache weil ich immer ihnen wie
fackeln in der hand hatte und dann war
es leider irgendwie immer so dass ich
hab ich hier nicht kakaobohnen die hab
ich auch nicht da war es leider
irgendwie immer so dass ich ja wenn du
einen krieg kam ich nie richtig werden
konnte allerdings müssen wir hier die
wand erstmal ein bisschen weiter zieht
mich bist hier vorne hin sagt er damit
dass auf jeden fall schonmal zugebaut
und hier vorne müssen wir das ganze dann
noch mal eben hochball eins zwei drei
vier blöcke muss das nämlich hoch das
ganze und dann sogar noch einen fünften
block obendrauf denn das wird dann die
dachhöhe sein der jeweils einer zu viel
kann ich mir ganz gut wieder abbauen
zack zack zack zack
und wenn ich dann hier untergeht seht
ihr schon dass wir hier dann so das dach
quasi rüberziehen werden und dann
brauche ich mich jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz hier mit unserem hellgrauen trocken
beton hoch wenn hier müssen wir auf
jeden fall auch einige quarzwerke
hinsetzen gehen nämlich so hier an der
seite lang dann hier vorne an der seite
drei rüber und hier an der anderen seite
müssen wir dann zurückgehen zu unserer
villa das wird nämlich ein bisschen
sonne abdach darstellen und hier vorne
dann auch 1234 so dass wir hier perfekt
abschneiden mit dem weg das ganze ziehen
wir dann rüber hier vorne hin und dann
haben wir auch gleich gar keinen
ein quarz mehr um das ja alles ein zu
bauen beziehungsweise zu bauen da muss
ich auf jeden fall noch mal ordentlich
farmen gehen in der hölle falls wir
irgendwelche tipps habe ich an mehr fans
kommen dann schnaps gerne in die
kommentare fielen ja auch geschrieben
dass ich einfach traden soll mit den
village allerdings hat das ja nie so
richtig funktioniert weil ich die erst
richtig krass hoch traden muss und da
ist halt einfach das problem dass das
sehr sehr sehr sehr lange dauert und
daher bin ich da wirklich angewiesen auf
eure tipps und ich werde jetzt auch hier
vorne den quad einfach mal doch so ein
bisschen hier zu ende hinsetzen zack und
hier den letzten den ich noch habe dann
werde ich mich auch schon dass das
kloster hier nicht mehr so komisch
irgendwie rum schild mitten in der luft
sondern jetzt wirklich eingebaut ist mit
dem kreuz hier vorsätzlich noch mal
einen hin und ihr seht jetzt auch schon
wo die reise so ein bisschen hingehen
soll das kann man glaube ich ein
bisschen besser erkennen wenn ich euch
das von hier einfach mal zeige dass sie
soll nämlich dann ab nach werden das
soll natürlich alles noch zu gebaut
werden wenn wir dann demnächst ein
bisschen mehr am start haben und hier
vorne rum soll das ab dann auch noch
gezogen werden dass hier muss ich noch
weiter zurück bauen da oben kommt dann
auch die zweite ebene darauf also die
zweite etage von unserer strandvilla ich
freue mich einfach drauf wenn dinge die
ich mal fällig ich hoffe wir schaffen
das noch in diesem projekt allerdings
haben wir den großteil wirklich schon
fertig unten ist ja auch schon alles
fast eingerichtet oben wird dann auf
jeden fall noch ganz geil die sache ist
jetzt dass ich an der stelle allerdings
das heutige video jetzt auch beenden
würde es ist glaube ich ein sehr
komisches video geworden wir können auch
hier mal ganz kurz um eine schweige
sekunde einlegen für die verstorbene
katze shui erster verstorbene wo die
pilze kühl und die schildkröte ich hätte
wirklich nicht gedacht dass in unserem
projekt so viele tierische okay ich
dachte schon das ballett irgendwie
abgehauen ist aber ich habe den er kurz
mitgenommen zustand in das heißt ihr
müsst ihr irgendwo frei rumlaufen glaube
ich wir fordern aber auf jeden fall das
schweinchen und ich würde auch sagen
dass das schweinchen gleich die letzten
worte hat meine lieben freunde denn an
der stelle wie gerade bereits gesagt
durch das heutige video hat auch beenden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann das gern
einen daumen hoch und ein video
abonniert main kanal und tig auf die
glocke wenn ihr noch keinen teil der
lupus alte und neue videos nicht
verpassen wollte ich weiß das ist heute
eine sehr traurige und sehr komische
folge war allerdings mussten wir einfach
ja wir mussten gut abschied nehmen und
dem coo von der kuh und von das schaf
von dem scharfen von der kuh
also ich hoffe es hat euch steht auch
ein bisschen neben der spur ich lag
heute morgen draußen in der sonne und
bin eingespart ja wenn ich noch ein
bisschen kaputt also da scheint die
letzten worte wir wollen die gut in
erinnerung halten kommen sagt wenigstens
noch ein neues video kommt übermorgen
ich hoffe schon
[Musik]